La economía se desacelera y muchas
marcas ya han comenzado a sacar cada vez
más producto de low ticket, es decir, de
un costo muy asequible. Viste el caso de
Apple con su computadora nueva Neo por
$599,
que además está haciendo todo una
revolución porque funciona muy bien,
seamos honestos, con tanta guía, muchas
herramientas son solamente en el
navegador, pero no viste también el caso
de Chanel, como el estuche de
maquillaje, pero con un cordón, ahora se
ha vuelto el bolso de tendencia que
muchas llevan cruzado así porque es así
como bien cookie. Esto, ¿qué significa?
Si vas y buscas en los datos, verás que
la ONU lo ha dicho. Para el 2026, la
economía se desacelera. Significa que
tenemos a un consumidor más cauteloso.
No es que no va a comprar, es que quiere
ver más opciones y que a lo mejor la
primera vez que quiera compar
asequible. Así que, ¿cuál va a ser tu
estrategia contra esta economía que
estamos viviendo?